♪♪
Hey, everybody.
Welcome back to "Corrections."
And let's get started.
I said there were no direct
flights from LaGuardia to LAX.
There is one.
There is one a week.
Do you want to guess what
airline it is, Shoemaker?
Spirit Airlines.
It's a true story.
Spirit Airlines has
a Saturday morning flight
from LaGuardia to LAX.
There's a rule at LaGuardia that
you cannot fly a flight
that's more than 1,500 miles
outside LaGuardia airport,
but that rule
is waived on Saturdays.
So Spirit Airlines
took advantage of it.
And, you know, if you're going
from New York to L.A.
and you want to see the stars,
they're probably not
on that flight.
[ Laughter ]
Someone from Spirit Airlines
actually reached out
to tell us that.
They didn't reach out directly.
They had to connect in Florida.
[ Laughter ]
We talked about people taking
horse pills, ivermectin.
Horse pills -- We said,
"Don't take horse pills
to treat COVID."
And a lot of people said,
"Look, you know,
the prescription ivermecshin --
ivermectin, excuse me,
is a pill.
The horse medicine ivermectin
is a paste.
So we should have said --
We were wrong to say,
"Don't eat horse pills.
What we should have said is,
"Don't eat horse paste."
So I guess we're the dummies.
In the back -- I think --
You know, and, again,
like, don't eat paste
in general.
If we learned anything
in kindergarten
that we could take with us
the rest of our life,
don't eat the paste.
We've talked about
the knitting community,
the foul-mouthed,
short-tempered,
incredibly diverse
knitting community.
And as a little
Easter egg for them,
on the back of my card
last week, I wrote,
"Knit one, purl two,
relax three."
I spelled purl "P-E-A-R-L."
So, once again,
they did what they --
Their natural state is outrage.
They said, "It's not --
You spelled it wrong.
It's P-U-R-L."
But that's not what I was doing.
I was saying,
"One, knitters, listen up.
Two, here is
a pearl of wisdom...
which is, three, relax."
Oh, this is bad.
I talked about Twiki the Robot,
said he was from
"Battlestar Galactica."
He's from "Buck Rogers."
And a lot of you said that
I did that on purpose.
I was, you know,
throwing out jackal bait.
I would -- First of all,
I would never do that --
I would never do that
for this, okay?
Because there was
a real cost when I did that.
I had my nerd card revoked.
And that's not just,
like, a thing.
That's a real thing
you have and you need.
Like, my nerd card has come in
super-handy, even recently.
I got to get the vaccine early,
because a nerd card --
When you have a nerd card,
they just assume you
have moderate-to-severe asthma.
And, by the way, asthma
community, don't come at me,
thinking I'm making fun of
people with asthma.
I got it.
I still carry an inhaler, okay?
You want to come at me
about my asthma,
you just name
the time and the place.
Ideally a place
without ragweed...
[ Laughter ]
...or pet dander.
You know what was really --
Patton Oswalt
was the one who called me to say
my nerd card was revoked.
So they had a friend do it.
But I will say this about Twiki.
A lot of people were like,
"You idiot.
Twiki was from 'Buck Rogers.'"
I'm not lying --
there were seven different
spellings of Twiki.
So you're not better than me.
Couple people spelled it Twiggy,
with two G's.
Twiggy, of course, was the...
robot in the short-lived sitcom
"Laverne & Shirley in Space."
[ Laughter ]
Twiggy and Len --
Len Bot and Twiggy.
where the robots --
they would...
[ Laughter ]
They would show up at
the funniest time.
Laverne and Shirley --
they'd be on the space station.
[ Laughter ]
And Shirley would be like, "I
don't know about space, Laverne.
There's the
creepiest creatures here."
[ Robotic voice ]
"Hello!"
Also, you know, I'll apologize
for getting wrong that Twiki
was from, you know,
"Buck Rogers" and not
"Battlestar," but you know
who else should apologize?
How about Buck Rogers for
thinking, in the 25th century,
this is what robots
would look like?
And we're barely into
the 21st century,
and, like, Boston Dynamics
has robots doing, like, parkour.
And they were like, "The
25th century, they'll have,
like, metal bowl cuts."
That's -- You know what
that actor is?
Gil Faizon.
"Charmed, I'm sure."
We've been talking about
"The New York Times"
spelling bee.
This is not a correction,
but it was really sweet.
The people over at
"The New York Times,"
the word-games people,
sent me a spelling-bee mug,
which I thought was very nice.
And a card, which surprised me,
because I just thought they'd
have better...
[ Laughter ]
...handwriting.
I don't know.
That's, like, foolish to
assume that people, like,
good at word games
would have good penmanship,
but that's --
that's a shame on me.
I finished the last corrections
by saying, "See you September."
And I was told by a
bunch of people,
I don't see you, you see me.
We had a graphic of an F Train
in a flooded 59th Street
subway station.
The F Train does not
stop at 59th Street.
I said "one or two things"
last night,
when I meant to say
"one of two things.
We talked about being taught
fractals in high school.
A lot of people said
you don't get taught
fractals in high school.
I also said it
would have been great if "AOC"
could have taught me math
in high school,
and a bunch of people,
which I think was very cruel,
said she wasn't even born when
I was in high school.
[ Laughter ]
But she was.
When I was a sophomore,
she was born.
A lot of --
I guess it's an old wives' tale.
You can go swimming right
after you eat.
You don't have to wait
30 minutes,
so just have a big old meal
and get right in the pool.
This was a little hurtful.
Someone said -- I guess --
You know, and, again,
not everybody has to like
"Corrections."
It's not for everyone.
Someone said, "How do I --"
This was a comment they left.
"How do I opt out of these?"
[ Laughter ]
So...
So, the cursor --
If you move it, there's --
It's, like -- There's like
two lines like this.
And then if you click --
It's, like, a --
Like, if you click it, it's --
It's, like, the universal
symbol for "pause."
You just hit it, and it stops.
And then you just go about it,
doing something else.
The film is called
"The Goonies,"
not "Goonies."
Also, it turns out,
a lot of movies were shot in
Astoria, Oregon,
where "The Goonies" is shot.
"Short Circuit,"
"Kindergarten Cop,"
"Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles III,"
"Ring Two."
Not bad.
My question to those of you
in Astoria --
do you have film tourism?
Do people who like those films
come to look around?
You know,
at the Astoria Airport,
which is in Warrenton --
shame on you --
can you buy a
"It's not a tumor" shirt?
[ Laughter ]
Or a "Number 5 is alive"
coffee mug.
It was just a question.
That's not a correction.
Talked about --
speaking of "The Goonies" --
the importance to remember,
when you're doing impressions,
don't do Sloth.
Sloth was a character
in "The Goonies."
And just don't do Sloth.
It's a hard -- A lot
of comedians who had, like,
big Sloth chunks
in their act complain now,
'cause they're
like, "I can't do Sloth."
And a lot of them,
like, that's their act now.
It's like,
"You can't do Sloth anymore."
But then a lot of them
still do Sloth.
I'm like, "Which is it?"
You know?
Can't have your Baby Ruth
and eat it, too.
Anyway, I talked about how
"Don't do Sloth"
is the motto of Impression Camp.
But it's in Latin.
I couldn't remember
the exact Latin of the seal
at Impression Camp,
but I wanted to get it right,
so I went to one of
our producers, Emily,
because we actually use
a translation service
whenever we do something
in a foreign language.
And I said, "Can you find out,
using the translation service,
how you would say,
'Don't do Sloth' in Latin?"
And she came back to me
and she showed me
the e-mail from
the translation service.
And they said,
"As you likely know --"
Seemed a little
passive-aggressive
right off the bat.
"As you likely know,
Latin is a dead language.
So we're not gonna be able to
get you an answer today."
You know, 'cause they said
they usually go to --
You know what kind --
What two professions
do you think they go to,
Shoemaker, to get Latin?
-Medical?
-Doctors. Correct.
-Legal.
-Priests.
-Oh!
-And I get it.
You don't want to, like --
They also said
they're notoriously
hard to get in touch with,
doctors and priests.
And I -- You wouldn't want to
interrupt a surgery
to find out how to say,
"Don't do Sloth."
"Doctor, stop what you're doing.
It's for
'Late Night with Seth Meyers.'
No, no, not broadcast."
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, so, we couldn't get
it from the translation service,
and so I had to go to
Google Translate.
And, guys, look,
when you go to Google Translate,
you've already lost.
It's already too late.
You're not gonna get
what you need going --
Google -- It's like when you --
It's like if
you want a picture taken of
you and your friends,
and the only person you
can find is a very old woman.
She'll take the picture, but
you're never gonna look at it.
So, I used Google Translate for
"Don't do Sloth."
And here's what someone
told me it translated to,
'cause, you know, of course,
the jackals all speak Latin.
"Do not make of the wild meat
for the para--"
[ Laughs ]
"Do not meek -"
"Do not make of the wild meat
for the paralysis."
"Don't do Sloth."
A lot of you have also
noted that when I
first mentioned Impression Camp
on this show,
I said it was a place
I went where they would
stop getting me
to do impressions,
but I've since
reframed as a place
where they've helped me
hone my impressions.
So, what happened was this.
I did originally go so that
I could stop
doing impressions, but then they
heard me do my impressions
and they said I have the gift.
[ Laughter ]
So they moved me from
Impression Camp to
Impression Academy.
And the dean of
Impression Academy --
a little guy, Rich...
[ Laughter ]
he came over
and he said, "Well --"
He always...
He would always start, "Well..."
I think...
[ Laughter ]
I think that's how he
gets into Reagan.
He goes,
"Well, you've got the gift."
God, what else?
[ Laughter ]
You'll see me --
Wait. No. Yeah.
You'll see me next week.
Happy?